have you ever gotten
a letter from your credit card company
saying we have decided
to lower your credit card limit from
fifteen thousand dollars to five
thousand dollars you ever experienced
that that's called tightening
you have easing increase your limit
tightening lowering your limit the
government just announced they're going
through tightening
that's what jamie dimon said they did
tightening back in 0809 for a couple
months you know what happened to the
market straight dip
every month they're saying they're going
to take roughly 95 billion dollars of
credit out so like every month imagine
they're gonna gradually lower your limit
so it's kind of like saying that fifteen
thousand dollar credit card limit
everyone's gonna go down a thousand
dollars
so to go from fifteen thousand dollars
to fourteen to thirteen to twelve so
you're not really gonna feel it suddenly
they're gradually doing it
conservatively so we're not gonna feel
it but they're taking money off the
table why are they doing that you'll see
here in a minute why they're doing that
that's tightening versus easing we are
about to go through tightening 08 was
easing
2022 is titan